[Música]
la presidenta interina de bolivia
jeanine áñez se retira de la campaña
electoral de cara a las elecciones
generales del 18 de octubre en un
intento por evitar el triunfo de luís
arce candidato del más partido del ex
presidente evo morales en un año es la
decisión no con un sacrificio sino un
honor
el presidente de perú martín vizcarra se
defenderá en el congreso del país
mientras los legisladores de la
oposición siguen adelante con un juicio
político criticado por ser un intento de
destitución precipitado vizcarra es
acusado de tráfico de influencias
tenemos reportes de ese link
en israel los ciudadanos se someten a un
nuevo confinamiento del país de 9
millones de habitantes alcanzó este mes
una de las tasas de contagios diarias de
ccoo y 19 más altas del mundo el de
confinamiento durará por lo menos tres
semanas y coincidirá con tres
importantes festividades judías
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 se revelan con
gusto saludarlos comenzamos a este
informativo en bolivia donde a un mes de
las elecciones presidenciales jeanine
áñez la actual presidenta interina
anunció su retiro de la contienda
electoral la declaración se produjo un
día después de que la encuesta electoral
más amplia difundida hasta ahora en esa
nación situar a agnès candidata por la
alianza juntos en cuarto lugar en
intención de voto lejos incluso del
poder que de poder disfrutar una segunda
vuelta con el primero en los sondeos el
candidato del partido más
luízar se informase andrea maya
hoy estamos acá jeanine áñez retira su
candidatura de las elecciones
presidenciales del próximo 18 de octubre
en bolivia las dos últimas encuestas le
asignan apenas un 8% de intención de
voto según áñez su decisión busca ayudar
a la victoria de los que no quieren la
dictadura refiriéndose a un posible
regreso del movimiento al socialismo el
partido del ex presidente evo morales-
hoy dejo de lado mi candidatura a la
presidencia de bolivia para cuidar la
democracia no es un sacrificio es un
honor porque lo hago ante el riesgo de
que se divide el voto democrático entre
varios candidatos y que a consecuencia
de esa división el más acabe ganando la
elección lo hago por la unidad de los
que amamos la democracia lo hago para
ayudar a la victoria de los que no
queremos la dictadura
en estas elecciones el ex ministro de
economía y delfín del exmandatario
morales luis arce lidera la intención de
voto representando al partido del
movimiento al socialismo que estuvo 14
años ininterrumpidos en el poder hasta
la partida de morales en medio de
violentas manifestaciones en el país por
supuesto fraude electoral
en segundo lugar está el candidato
carlos meza del partido de comunidad
ciudadana y segundo en las encuestas
a asumir el mandato transitorio el 12 de
noviembre de 2019 pero su gobierno ha
sido acusado de corrupción durante la
pandemia violación de los derechos
humanos y un mal manejo de la crisis
sanitaria bolivia está entre los países
de la región con la peor tasa de
mortalidad por coronavirus
un candidato que recupera popularidad es
luís fernando camacho quien empezó a
emerger en los últimos días el líder
regional de santacruz podría convertirse
en el voto de oro para el que será el
nuevo presidente de bolivia y el
presidente de perú martín vizcarra se
enfrenta a un juicio político en el
congreso después de que el tribunal
superior rechazó la apelación de su
gobierno para bloquear la votación el
congreso votó la semana pasada a favor
de abrir un proceso de juicio político
contra el presidente de 57 años por
incapacidad moral está acusado de
supuestamente incitar a sus asesores a
mentir a los investigadores anti
sobornos desde las afueras del congreso
en lima se encuentra nuestro
corresponsal francisco zacarías
francisco buen día le pregunto cómo va a
transcurrir la jornada el día de hoy en
aquel congreso de perú decide el futuro
del presidente vizcarra
buenos días el juicio político al
presidente de martín vizcarra se inicia
a las 9 de la mañana para esta hora ha
sido programada la sesión en la que se
ha citado a los legisladores se tiene
previsto que el mandatario ejerza su
defensa a partir de las 10 en punto y
tendrá una hora para hacerlo
posteriormente a esto se iniciará un
debate en el cual los legisladores
tendrán una duración de unas cuantas
horas para debatir y esto podría durar
unas cuantas horas como he señalado
extenderse a lo largo de la noche
posteriormente ellos votarán y decidirán
sin martín vizcarra continúa siendo
presidente o le declara la vacancia
presidencial hay que señalar que el
mandatario de acuerdo a la constitución
no está obligado a asistir al
impeachment y el el tampoco ha dado a
conocer su intención de hacerlo es por
eso que todas las miradas están
centradas en su abogado roberto pereira
francisco cuáles son los argumentos de
su defensa la defensa del presidente
el autor roberto pereyra ha señalado que
su defensa se centrará en que no existen
causas suficientes para declarar la
vacancia presidencial por incapacidad
moral él ha advertido que la
constitución peruana no establece que
los audios puedan ser elementos
suficientes jurídicamente para destituir
al mandatario y vamos a ver cómo le va
al presidente oa su abogado en esta
sesión en el parlamento peruano
francisco gracias por información que
tenga usted un feliz resto de día por
supuesto muy pendientes de lo que ocurra
en lima la capital peruana sobre el
futuro del presidente vizcarra y
cambiamos de información hablemos ahora
de la pandemia de koi 19 el mundo superó
los 30 millones de casos confirmados del
nuevo corren a virus y varios lugares
del planeta están viendo un
resurgimiento de los contagios entre
ellos israel que hoy viernes 18 de
septiembre entró en un nuevo
confinamiento generalizado de tres
semanas que coincide con el comienzo de
las fiestas judías que se extienden
hasta el 11 de octubre y la noticia no
es del gusto de todos
fue anunciada el domingo pasado
provocando estupor entre los israelíes
un país entero obligado a reactivar el
aislamiento para frenar la epidemia el
método es cuestionado por cientos de
manifestantes reunidos en tel aviv entre
ellos científicos y médicos
el confinamiento es ineficaz e incluso
desastroso hace más daño que cualquier
otra cosa no va a detener la pandemia
cierre de escuelas restaurantes salas de
deportes y todas las tiendas no
esenciales durante tres semanas a los
israelíes también se les prohíbe moverse
a más de 500 metros de sus casas y
reunirse en grupos de más de diez
personas en interiores 20 al aire libre
un arsenal de medidas en un momento en
el que el país se enfrenta a un
preocupante resurgimiento del virus la
tasa de contagio en israel es ahora una
de las más altas del mundo y hay cientos
de pacientes en los servicios de
emergencia muchos de ellos en estado
grave según el primer ministro benjamin
netanyahu hay que evitar la saturación
del sistema de sal
en los últimos dos días hemos visto un
nuevo aumento alarmante de la mortalidad
y un aumento constante del número de
pacientes en condiciones críticas la
situación y las recomendaciones de
muchos especialistas no nos dejan otra
opción que reforzar las medidas
entre confinamiento que según la
oposición israelí podría tener efectos
devastadores en la economía ya golpeada
por la primera ola las nuevas medidas
entraron en vigor en la víspera del año
nuevo judío un tiempo de celebraciones
tanto religiosas como familiares
continuamos hablando del coronavirus
pero esta vez nos vamos hasta francia
donde el número de personas contagiadas
y en las que tienen que ser tratadas en
unidades de cuidados intensivos porque
hoy 19 sigue en aumento un ejemplo claro
de la crisis en ascenso es marsella la
segunda ciudad más grande del país
allí el incremento de pacientes se
agudizó los hospitales públicos sin
capacidad te están transfiriendo a sus
pacientes a centros privados
este hospital está al borde de su
capacidad en su unidad de cuidados
intensivos siete de cada diez camas son
ocupadas por pacientes con coronavirus
en un esfuerzo por bajar la presión 20%
de los enfermos fueron transferidos a
clínicas privadas el problema no es que
no tengamos suficientes recursos sino
que no tenemos suficiente personal para
ayudar no hay suficientes enfermeras
calificadas para trabajar en cuidados
intensivos no hay suficientes asistentes
de enfermería ni tampoco suficientes
doctores el hospital ha traído si en
cuidadores extra para unirse a la
primera línea pero esto sólo alivia una
parte de la carga en el departamento de
bocas del ródano más de 100 personas
están en cuidados intensivos la
situación en bocas del ródano extensa
para darte una idea general sólo tenemos
una docena de camas para pacientes con
kobe y en total sólo 30 de 200 están sin
ocupar
en la región de provence a más de 600
personas son tratadas por kobe 19 sólo
en la última semana 7000 ciudadanos
dieron positivo y es que españa también
ve con preocupación como su en los casos
de hoy
19 madrid es la ciudad más afectada y la
presidenta de la región anunciará nuevas
medidas como confinamiento selectivos y
también restricción a la movilidad las
nuevas redes trick ciones entrarán en
vigor este fin de semana
unos cuarenta y ocho migrantes saltaron
por la borda del barco de rescate
español open arms al mar mediterráneo en
un intento de nadar hacia la cercana
ciudad de palermo en el sur de italia
ese segundo día consecutivo que un grupo
de emigrantes salta al mar por la
delicada y compleja situación a bordo
open arms llevó a cabo tres operaciones
de rescate por separado en el
mediterráneo central entre el 8 y 10 de
septiembre rescatando a más de 270
personas
la tripulación todavía está esperando
instrucciones sobre dónde se permitirá
desembarcar
la hora depresión tropical salí que tocó
tierra en la costa de alabama en eeuu
con fuerza de huracán avanza por georgia
dejando graves inundaciones a su paso y
al menos una persona fallecida de
momento de las zonas más afectadas por
las inundaciones son alabama y la parte
norte de florida donde las
precipitaciones han sido intensas debido
al lento desplazamiento de la tormenta
de esa región de las costas del golfo de
méjico se enfrenta ahora a una
recuperación de los daños millonarios
ocasionados por las lluvias de la
posible llegada de otras tres tormentas
en el atlántico
el presidente bielorruso alexandr
lukashenko cerró las fronteras con
polonia y lituania y también fortaleció
sus controles fronterizos con la vecina
ucrania entretanto del consejo de
derechos humanos de la onu celebra un
debate urgente sobre presuntos abusos
contra los derechos humanos en belarús
debido a los informes de detenciones
indiscriminadas y también violentas
además de la tortura de manifestantes
pacíficos a raíz de la reelección de
alexander lukashenko en el mes de agosto
fuimos testigos de miles de arrestos
cientos de reportes de tortura
incluyendo violencia sexual e incluso
tortura reportada contra niños también
el secuestro violento de personas a
plena luz del día por parte de personas
enmascaradas en un principio sólo por
expresar de manera pacífica sus
opiniones expresó opiniones
y policía armada y personal de seguridad
están siendo desplegados en un patrón
sistemático de violencia excesiva contra
los manifestantes que en su mayoría son
pacíficos en la litis folk de más
tractores y la crisis derivada de la
pandemia ha provocado que aumente la
pobreza por ingresos en méxico y a la
gente en situación de calle se han
sumado desempleados que buscan la
beneficiencia y la solidaridad para
tener una comida caliente al día el
informe desde mario carbonero
adentro de lunes a viernes en este
comedor vicentino misioneros y
voluntarios preparan raciones de comida
para la gente necesitada pedimos al
señor que le agrega a estos alimentos
pero la crisis que trajo el cubit ha
hecho esos religiosos redoblar esfuerzos
y afuera decenas de personas hacen filas
desde el mediodía en espera de recibir
los alimentos que manda el gobierno de
la ciudad a este comedor javier coordina
la recepción de los platillos y es él
quien hace la entrega de las 280
raciones aumentó a 400 acciones ya que
ha habido en 13 empleados sobre todo
viene mucha mamás soltera
en el chico más de un millón de personas
han perdido su empleo durante la
pandemia ya este comedor en el centro de
la ciudad diario llega alguien en esa
situación
eladio es veterinario y también para le
obras pero el confinamiento afectó su
centro de trabajo por ello viene aquí
porque manda una fuente de ingresos
mayores a la del archivo desde el
asentamiento por la pandemia nos
cerraron ahora estoy esperando para
poder iniciar de nuevo cuenta mi
actividad como investigador a nueve
kilómetros al cliente la historia se
repite con un restaurante de antojitos
mexicanos como el comedor vicentino a
este restaurante comenzó a llegar no
sólo gente en situación de calle sino
también víctimas del desempleo llegó
adrián de 20 años perdió su trabajo
cuando se confinó el poder judicial
de limpieza limpiaba las malvinas
aquí también aumentaron las raciones que
regalan diariamente y procuran que nunca
se vaya a alguien sin recibir algo de
comida al segundo trimestre del año el
porcentaje de personas en pobreza
laboral fue de 48.1 por ciento aunque
instituciones como el consejo nacional
de evaluación de políticas de desarrollo
estiman que la pandemia aumentará hasta
en 10 millones más las personas en
pobreza por ingresos y de esta manera
llegamos al final de la informativa en
france 24 continúa con nosotros porque
hay mucho más para ver aquí en nuestro
canal feliz día
[Música]
la información al momento en france 24 y
france 24 puntos